it's minus eight degrees on the picket
line outside Oxford's warnford Hospital
the nurses here undeterred
does passing cars honk their support
they're joining colleagues across
England Wales and Northern Ireland in
the first strikes of their kind in the
history of the National Health Service a
service that many say is on the brink of
collapse we've lost thousands thousands
and thousands of nurses during the
pandemic but pre-pandemic and post
pandemic actually the nursing profession
has been chronically affected by our
government and things that have happened
in the world for a really really long
time
we met one of the nurses Rachel Ambrose
at home the day before the strike
full-time heating is no longer
affordable so when the children are out
at school it's freezing she's been a
nurse for 20 years and for much of that
time Rachel says her salary has been
stagnant or fallen in real terms as the
cost of living particularly this year
has gone up
we were averaging about 160 pounds a
month and that was already an increase
from the April I think when it went up
and yeah it shut up it's nearly 400
pound now prices just keep going up and
we're just expected to swallow it and
it's it's not physically possible and so
it is time that we took a stand and yeah
we're basically asking for what has been
lost over this past
um you know 10 15 years and we just want
a fair wage you know we're not asking
for treats we're just asking and for a
fair wage so we can afford to continue
working as nurses
back on the picket line the nurses say
they regret the effect strikes will have
on non-urgent patient care but they say
the effect of Staff shortages caused by
those leaving the service is worse
the nurses are asking for a 19 pay rise
or five percent above inflation to meet
they say a 20 fall in real terms wages
in recent years it's a negotiating
position that the government so far
isn't engaging with Beyond around four
percent currently on the table any more
they say will have to be paid for in
higher taxes
support has grown as the day goes on the
nurses joined by representatives of
other unions it's not only health care
that's under pressure but Railways
airports the Border Force bus drivers
and more the government facing a winter
wave of disruption right across the
public sector Jonah Hall Al Jazeera
Oxford